walk him to this video playing just one
guitar this is a relatively frequent
opponent four out of six as my sky play
it didn't play him for a while I believe
so let's go to them as a Michigan at
least check in this kind of opening I
know what to do trying to try to go for
checkmate oops quick night age five hmm
hmm interesting never saw that move
maybe maybe my move order is wrong I
don't know okay probably this to prevent
queen age four and then it goes f 5m
yeah this is some stop very comfortable
okay he'd retreats voluntarily I was
wondering if I should really plain item
tonight g3 get rid of this night okay
probably to d3 the night on off fo at
least prevents any deeper moves so it
cannot move these six at any point 3065
very difficult to play that now this
looks okay this should be okay for what
at least it's nothing especially
grateful black okay
yeah but if wire isn't it for now we
move takes takes okay i would like to i
would like to have my rooks connected
for that maybe maybe this first and then
a form now I always have 95 the problem
is the move g 6 cm so in a I go if we
form this diagonal d22 g5 to h6 gets
opened and on e5 always have 95 with a
very very pleasant position I probably
remove an important defender the King
side or the bishop and I'm not quite
sure but maybe I'm threatening me five
here yeah in the concrete position yeah
I'm threatening me five which however is
covered here takes Knight takes on g6 is
not convincing let's see um can I
prepare it somehow D 5 D 5 he probably
goes Knight c5 it's not very helpful
55 hmm how do I get get the bishop on
age 6 I can't claim maybe night age
three maybe night age three here
intending Bishop g5 95 bishop age 695
could be good could be good not sure
maybe it's good maybe not nigera ply him
but ok but I have Bishop g5 Queenie to
mark a 94 it's not a problem I don't
really like this position very much for
black maybe I'm too optimistic yeah this
is a good move probably trying to cover
age 6 I wonder if I should just play
Quincy one getting this this in 195 and
then rupee 8 ok let's play that on
nigera ply we should be two is one of
them one night g fire is also possible
oh great this I completely overlooked
Wow
wow I just I just didn't see that this
poor Hanks great this is getting better
and better check funny thing is that
it's still probably not bad for widen
the bishop one age six is a very check a
very problematic piece provide unless
there is some tactic that I'm again
overlooking then white isn't in bad
shape him the bishop is covering f8
which is the most important thing
an idea next is Queen III rook f1
getting the rook on their farm okay if i
go here 93 years coming so problem
probably need some improvement on that
33 Knight c3 and the check is not not
how I look everyone is not helping very
much
poor I don't really want to take on your
form this looks really like a bad choice
maybe queen e 1 what is happening on
Queenie one difficult with one minute
yeah yeah I thought I can maybe take a
95 on next Queen III rook everyone look
at 195 m this is this should be okay
with all pieces side morning
participating with this attack on the
dark squares yeah prominent YouTube now
you might gain some time with Queen d65
something like that I cannot trade
queens I cannot go to h3 because of
night f2 why it's getting sick here is
really getting sick I mean white was
again very very good shape and I'm
blundering this now poor that's really
frustrating
there any way to to fight yet Queen can
always give you three check and win
problem check not in fact yeah this is
quincy for is made what check check
white forfeits on time yeah no comment
on that just yeah it's my own fault of
cosine after i blundered the poor like
like once again outplayed and then I
just blundered this unbelievable Brooke
f1 by the way or 95 I don't know I can i
can probably allow the Queen trade if I
go here yeah this is this is in fact
even winning rook f7 assume it's just
coming next with a winner okay f77 the
problem is the dark squares he's just
totally dead on the dark squares okay
this is some this is not good and then
I'd run run right into 94 how stupid can
you be a and Knight takes e4 in fact is
still playable great yeah I can do that
text the Queen and secures this is even
good for what great yeah check twin g4s
made in one and studied just gave away
the night and then he gave up the queen
because he's realest winning on time
yeah
yeah what a bad game I mean around here
the game is excellent for white just am
having a totally dominant center just a
matter how to correctly play now the
computer points out a very strong will
see 5 which which I didn't see at all
it's very strong B takes is a bad
because of these kind of ideas with
attacking here and here 1i g5 first and
here 95 is also very strong black is
collapse I'm only six okay and I just I
just blundered afore I mean just like
that yeah if I'm okay missing c-5m okay
but I can play any move instead set it
instead of giving up the porn and I'm
just better something like that look
everyone it's a very one-sided position
where I'm just padding up pieces on the
King side yeah okay not much that I can
do thanks for watching